well record high gas prices most likely
causing you to kind of rethink how much
you actually drive nevada is ranked
second highest in the country when it
comes to gas prices with an average of
553 a gallon victoria saha joins us near
tropicana in durango and victoria there
are ways that drivers can save right
yes any so we just finished filling up
our news car here and look at that price
for just nine gallons if you have no
choice but to drive daily you probably
are dreading pulling up to the gas pump
driving is inevitable for many southern
nevadans you're most likely looking up
gas prices to find the cheapest i'm
budgeting up the wazoo drivers like
holly larson are cutting out any
unnecessary driving i don't do anything
after work like once a week i go hang
out with friends and that's like it i
just i can't afford to go anywhere else
she has to pump the brakes on her
frequent drives to california to see
family i can't afford to do anything
because i've got to pay for gas to get
to work with prices up 30 cents in the
last month gas station owners are also
feeling the pain at the pump we've
noticed a downturn in our gallons a
little bit where traditionally this
would be a
heavy uh driving season have you ever
had it this high
i don't ever remember it being this high
ever i've been with fabulous freddies
for
20 plus years and we've never even come
close to these kinds of prices just have
to work harder to
keep up with these prices or find other
alternatives like pablo leo has if you
get a car wash you know you can knock
off some of the price too
and points and stuff so there's little
ways to save so will costco or sam's
club memberships need a gift shop or eat
out buy gift cards to retailers and
restaurants at the grocery store and
earn fuel points there's always those
apps that you can save 10 cents or 15
cents depending on
which one you're using like i know shell
has them
back out here live another way to save
is find gas stations that offer lower
prices if you pay with cash or debit and
letting your car remove any excess
weight and you will get better gas
mileage victoria zaha live local now